Microsoft translators speech translation
technology incorporates two different
artificial intelligence systems when
audio first enters the system it goes
through a neural network that
transcribes the audio into text however
as we speak we often unknowingly repeat
or use filler words such as um or like
in English the speech translation system
knows this and removes these filler
words to produce a translation that
makes sense
the system uses a natural language
processing technology called true text
which normalizes the text and finds the
most appropriate words based on the
context of the full sentence
once the text is normalized it goes
through a second AI system neural
machine translation this additional
neural network translates the text into
the target language in this case English
to Japanese
if the application also offers an audio
output such as the Microsoft translator
live feature a speech synthesizer or
text-to-speech will then enunciate the
text and the user will be able to hear
the audio translation in their own
language